et puis d'abord ce formidable cocorico
du tennis français cet après midi au
tournoi de roland garros le coq a chanté
deux fois et on en était tout ému pensez
donc en demi finale yannick noah
rencontrera un autre français christophe
roger vasselin
commençons par le dernier résultat
acquis celui de noah face à lindahl
victoire en quatre sets pour yannick
noah à roland garros tout le monde
attend doigt pour son premier match face
à un grand du tennis mondial le fonds
s'était concentré remporte le premier
set au tie-break il le fallait pour
éviter à tout prix décrocher ce bac en
conscience sûr de son tennis nous a
remporté la deuxième manche sans bavure
6 2 sur sa lancée noah continue de bien
jouer et impose un match de combat à
lendl pour mener 5-2 dans le troisième
set avec deux balles de match mais noah
crack l'accord de gagner sans doute et
s'incline 7 1
[Applaudissements]
le public compte sur lui il lui faut se
ressaisir
alors que l'on craignait que noah ne se
ressente moralement de la perte de cette
troisième manche
ils attaquent de nouveau l'inde elle
subit la rencontre un bundle qui sur la
quatrième balle de match sourit en
servant il sait qu'il a perdu 6 0 dans
le quatrième set 7-6 6-2 5-7 6-0 le
compte est bon
noah est heureux nous aussi il
rencontrera vendredi en demi finale
roger vasselin qu'il faut remonter à
1946 pour voir deux français en demi
finale de roland garros
champagne pour le tennis français
[Applaudissements]
c'est hubert c'était dur c'était un peu
plus décontracté qu'il ya quelques temps
ça a été dur
d'avoir deux balles de match comme ça au
troisième set et qui abat un passage à
vide et des recettes chez grand berger
beaucoup bon berger il ya eu un jeu très
important début du quatrième où j'ai des
balles de break contre moi j'ai
finalement fait ça m'a un peu
décontractée
j'ai pensé c'est très très bien passé
par la suite je suis vraiment content
c'est parce que vous avez pensé que
c'était finalement pratiquement une
place en finale que non c'est pas le
disait pas une place en finale de jouer
contre christophe ci qui jusque là fait
un parcours parfait dire il a très bien
joué contre commence aujourd'hui sur
plan tactique on se connaît bien je veux
dire c'est un peu je regrette un peu de
jouer contre christophe pas tellement
que j'ai pas d'oubli mais que bon on est
tous les deux en plein âge et on va être
obligé un nouvel être obligé de
s'arrêter
c'est un peu dommage de jouer contre
bassin mais finale de roland garros et
c'est dommage
énergie enfin bon il y aura plus
d'amitié sur le court j'ai dit et je
vais essayer de jouer pour gagner